this is Michael Bryce I'm an executive  protection agent I've extracted my  client clean up is required you might  want to call the bomb squad they get the  fire department isn't my car I'm afraid  so  have a seat it's been a long  one of the world's most brutal dictators  with a key witness to testify I can  assure you my mother Bernice Oh Kincaid  is dead no big baby I have a job what 27  times  that's how many times he tried to kill  me 28 where your husband is you lost my  husband do you have any idea how stupid  yourself in a way Bryson Kincaid op  makes it so thank you each other first  if you wouldn't mind the gun  no I've done  okay hunt 3-1 my bad your bad  Oh God this man's killed over 150 people  250 easy  [Music]